it's happening a supporter of domestic
terrorists is now on the homeland
security committee Marjorie Taylor green
the radical republican congresswoman a
joke of a woman making the United States
a global laughingstock
who defended and supported the domestic
terrorists who stormed the capital on
January 6th of 2021 who pushed 9 11
conspiracy theories who talked about
Jewish space lasers she will sit on the
homeland security committee the woman
that said they would have been armed and
would have won if she led the January
6th coup
is now on the homeland security
committee the homeland security
committee should be investigating people
like Marjorie Taylor green but it is
Marjorie Taylor Greene who in this
backwards United States ends up on that
very committee who does she think are
the threats people like Hunter Biden
people who she claims are socialists and
Communists even though they are not you
know the drill Rolling Stone reporting
the new GOP controlled house is letting
liars and conspiracy theorists lead its
agenda that is exactly right Kevin
McCarthy the new Speaker of the House
indicated he will allow Congressman
George Santos currently facing multiple
investigations for lying to voters about
his identity to also have a committee
position we're going to get to that
later on in the program
Rolling Stone reminds us green was
removed from the house education and
labor committee and the budget Committee
in February of 21 over backlash from
statements she made before her election
including that a Bullet to the Head was
the quickest way to remove Nancy Pelosi
from her then speakership green was also
revealed to Harbor a belief in Q Anon
having spread conspiracy theories about
mass shootings and suggested 9 11 was a
hoax green will now serve on the
homeland security committee I think it's
great Kevin McCarthy reportedly said on
Tuesday
some of Green's priorities she recently
said to Tucker Carlson she believes that
current Department of Homeland Security
secretary majorcus should be impeached
Paul gozar is also on the committee for
natural resources he was censured by the
house and ousted after he tweeted that
anime battle sequence where
um Alexandria ocasio-cortez was killed
Kevin McCarthy sure had to cut some
pretty damn wild deals to get those
votes and become speaker of the house
that is abundantly clear this is the
United States of America in 2023. you
support a failed coup you defend the
rioters you say if you had been in
charge of the coup you would have won
the coup you get to stay in congress by
the way
and then you get a job on the committee
in charge of Homeland Security
this is where we are and what of her
experience even ostensibly qualifies for
her for this role is it the harassment
she engaged in of the victims of school
shootings does that qualify her to be on
the homeland security committee is it
any of the long list of things we've
talked about before it is embarrassing
that this is where the country is and
you know how it'll go two years from now
we'll look back and we'll say what are
Marjorie Taylor Green's accomplishments
on this committee
and there will be none nothing positive
anyway and then they will say well we
couldn't get anything done because of
Democrats in the senate or whatever but
definitely vote for me again because now
I'm part of the in group and that's
really what this is about from Audrey
Taylor green and also that's a lot of
the of the Catalyst for this new war
she's engaged in with fellow lunatic
congresswoman Lauren bobert and that's
what I want to talk about next Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert two
dangerously delusional members of
Congress got into a verbal fight in the
women's bathroom when dim-witted dunce
clashes with brainless buffoon this is
what you get
uh it is being reported by The Daily
Beast and summarized by lgbtq Nation
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
allegedly got into a screaming match in
the women's restroom
um both green and bobert have said trans
women are a threat to CIS women in
public restrooms and locker rooms but it
appears the real aggression in the
women's room writes this article is
coming from them the two far-right
anti-lgbtq plus extremists reportedly
got into a shouting fight January 3rd
just as Congress was getting ready to
vote for speaker of the house according
to several unnamed sources who spoke to
the Daily Beast
during the 15 votes that lasted for an
entire week you might remember that
bobert and some others were trying to
prevent Kevin McCarthy from being
speaker green is a member of that same
Wing sometimes known as the freedom
caucus but she ended up siding with
McCarthy as we now know
the article goes on to say according to
One Source green was exiting a stall
when she confronted bobair about the
latter's plan to thwart McCarthy's
election green allegedly accused bobert
of taking money from McCarthy for her
campaign but not showing loyalty now she
allegedly asked you were okay taking
millions of dollars from McCarthy but
you refused to vote for him for speaker
Lauren green questioned Beau Bear's
loyalty to McCarthy and afterwards were
exchanged bobert stormed out that's when
Lauren said don't be ugly before bobert
quote ran out like a little school girl
when questioned about the altercation
bobert said see you later bye
Greene hasn't commented either
uh congresswoman Debbie Dingle Denzel
Dingle was reportedly in the restroom
when this happened but she's not talking
about it what happens in the Ladies Room
stays in the ladies room this is um this
is part of this splintering of the
Republican party I know I've said it
before I you know apologies for those
who have heard this but you originally
had Republicans Pro and anti-trump
people like you know Mitt Romney in the
anti-trump camp you now still have the
anti-trump Republicans but you have Maga
or buffoonery call it whatever you want
call it peaches for all I care to quote
Trump
um you now have Maga subdividing and
splintering and of course the dream
scenario would be that they splintered
themselves into Oblivion whether it's
going to happen or not we just don't yet
know but um Lauren bobert and Marjorie
Taylor green ending up on opposite sides
of anything is certainly a sign that
that splintering is taking place the
important thing for the left is you know
I have never pushed for this false Unity
of the left there's room for diverse
views on the left and there are also
things that just aren't actually left
and so we shouldn't pretend that they
are it's not about false Unity but right
now the left actually is quite United
these voices that I've always said are
relatively small in terms of power
they're very loud but they're relatively
small
um that do the Purity tests and the
litmus tests they are not getting nearly
the attention that they once did and
overall the left is pretty damn United
right now I think that it's critical at
a time when the right is splintering and
sub splintering and sub splintering add
infinitum hopefully
um that the left uh maintain focused on
the big issues that we are trying to
deal with that includes getting people
Health Care dealing with inequality
um help climate there's so many I don't
even know in what order to go the
education crisis the foreign policy
embarrassments that plagued this under
Trump on and on and on the left has an
opportunity to in contrast to what's
happening on the right look quite
organized and sane and United and allow
the right to continue destroying itself
meanwhile Republicans continue to just
do self-inflicted damage and I want to
talk about the the new anti-museum
anti-book positions that are surfacing
on the right
oh man where to even start with this
Candace Owens
has proudly and defiantly come out
against museums against museums we have
long spoken about the anti-intellectual
and pseudo-intellectual leanings of the
American right wing they used to sort of
couch them in a more uh what's the word
I don't want to say more defensible but
compared to now a slightly more
defensible way but now it is just
completely overt these are really
pathetic people and they are playing to
the lowest common denominator
a huge swath of the American right wing
doesn't read
doesn't think critically has no media
literacy skills and they just want their
beliefs spoon fed to them by Fox News
and people like Candace Owens and Ben
Shapiro and others and in order to keep
them in that state
right-wing influencers like Candace
Owens have started to make them feel
proud and confident in their beliefs
that books are bad learning is bad
museums are bad and here is a segment of
Candace Owens talking about how she's
actually very anti-museum take a look at
this next question what are your
thoughts on the British Museum and their
artifacts from other cultures yeah they
have returned many of them to Nigeria do
you think they should return them all
Jensen you know I actually kind of hate
a lot of museums because they seal our
tax dollars and so yeah defund all the
museums and send back all the artifacts
the amount of money that was given in
the covid bill the trillions of dollars
all of it going to like the Kennedy
Center the African-American Museum and
what do they do people that sit on the
boards take all the money it's kind of
become this huge money laundering
operation and yeah I say return it all
if you want to see something go to the
country you know so I'm actually totally
fine with that because only because I'm
very anti-museum because they stole a
lot of our money yeah interestingly she
pronounces museum museum which was but
the only two people I know that do that
are former producer Lewis and Candace
Owens we years ago we were wondering
where did Lewis get this Museum
pronunciation maybe he and Candace Owens
uh went to that same ritzy school in
Connecticut right no in all seriousness
this is the type of thing that many
right-wing and Republican voters
consider fresh and interesting and sort
of uh on the Vanguard of think uh the
modern Republicans love this stuff and
her idea is go to the country right I
mean if you want to see historical
artifacts like Egyptian mummies and
Roman statues and Greek pottery just go
to the countries it's just lying around
there you can just see it or if you want
to see
um you know artwork from famous artists
whether it's the Mona Lisa or you know
Van Gogh starry night or whatever go to
the countries whatever that means if you
want to see important documents like the
Magna Carta or the Gutenberg Bible or
whatever go to the country whatever the
hell that means this is part of a bigger
movement that includes Clips like this
this is Andrew taint
explaining why he is above reading books
he's above it he's too good or too smart
or too strong or whatever reading books
is a very cheap way to I guess entertain
I wouldn't call it entertainment because
my brain is far too advanced I'm too
smart to read right you're sitting there
go smart people read no I need action I
need constant chaos in my life to feel
content I need to be driving a Supercar
and fighting [ __ ] a bunch of hoes and
champagne and going crazy I can't just
sit there oh why would you read a book
when you can have champagne going crazy
just exploding explosive champagne all
over the place you're not gonna be
bothered with a book and the pirate on
the boat
for people with slow brains right so
this is now now by the way do I do I
even really need to mention by the way
it actually
takes more brain power
and it's so fraught to use the term
intelligence it requires lots of brain
power
to actually go and get the information
out of a book rather than sitting there
with explosive champagne watching
reality TV now I have no problem with TV
or any of it right I watch TV I watch
shows Kaleidoscope on Netflix right now
by the way really good you know but the
idea of books are for the Lesser thinker
sort of thing is part of the same I'm
against museums or museums or whatever
pronunciation you choose and this is all
either with Candace Owens I believe it's
deliberate with Andrew taint I think
it's not I think he's just kind of
stumbling across nonsense part of it is
make the people that follow you feel
good about just getting all of their
beliefs from you without thinking about
them too much without reading without
learning without looking at alternative
sources they benefit from people
thinking books no not for me
folks we are in a crisis on YouTube
something is happening on YouTube where
our Channel and others like ours appear
to be getting de-prioritized by some
kind of algorithm
I will have more information about this
when I have it please remember like the
video leave a comment hit the Subscribe
button it's really the it's free and
everybody can do it and it will help us
at youtube.com slash the David Pacman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
lying Republican Congressman George
Santos would use a fake Jewish sounding
name to raise money from Jews folks I I
can't I can't it's there is no depth to
low for this guy this is just
unbelievable CNN's Anderson Cooper
interviewed Gregory Maury Parker this is
a former friend and roommate of George
Santos and in speaking to Anderson
Cooper Maury
um uh Maury Parker explains that when
George Santos would run gofundme's which
is another scam which we will get to if
he needed to entice Jewish donors he
would use a Jewish last name listen to
this how long did you actually live
together
we were only uh roommates for a few
months and I also knew him as uh Anthony
zabrovski
so you knew him
why did he say he had two names then
well he he used the brovsky for his uh
friends of pets United his
um
is GoFundMe and he would say oh well you
know the Jews will give more if you're a
Jew and so that's the name he used for
his gofundme's and what was he having
gofundme's for back then hmm uh his he
had a bad charity friends of pets United
uh it was supposedly to help out with
you know sick animals and things like
that there's actually
um just an article released from one of
my reporters
uh who's been interviewing me a lot uh
Jacqueline sweet about how he conned a
homeless military vet out of three
thousand dollars for his uh service dog
okay we're gonna get back to that second
part but using the last name zabrovsky
zabroski zabrovsky I don't know which
version in order to entice Jewish donors
to donate now there is a ton of Jewish
related stuff going on with uh George
Santos where he claimed to be Jewish in
terms of his family history another
example is he got into a discussion on a
podcast called Loud majority about
whether Jewish people learn Spanish or
not take a listen to this I actually
think we should do the whole the rest of
this in Spanish I think so let's see how
your public education took out he went
to private school right I didn't tell
you I didn't do no I didn't do no school
there you go right I you know what I did
really I'm supposed to learn Spanish
Jewish people don't learn Spanish no
they don't because that's how they
become more culture
at least am I learning Spanish yeah
that's how I learned now and then now
this is when he was still lying about
being Jewish you'll notice it's lies on
top of lies on top of Lies now Beyond
parody this guy the the George Santos
that we now know lied about everything
and soon you will see built a disabled
veteran out of money for his dog and the
dog died okay
he has been assigned to the house small
business committee and the science space
and Technology committee here is a
report from yesterday from MSNBC George
Santos is going to serve on two
committees in the House of
Representatives on behalf of the
Republican conference they will be the
small business committee and the space
science and technology committees and I
actually just caught up with the house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy a few minutes ago
as he was leaving the Capitol he
confirmed to me our reports about The
Santos committee assignments and yeah so
he's going to be on committees this guy
who has lied about everything scammed
people stolen money lied about inventing
carbon capture technology lied about
being Jewish lied everything
he gets committee assignments and one
other funny note from this interview
with Santos's former roommate with
Anderson Cooper I guess that the Santos
stole a scarf
from his friend and then wore it to the
stop the steel Rally or whatever I
understand he was actually wearing
something he took from you at a
pre-january 6th rally in Washington
he has the audacity yes wait a minute
he's wearing the scarf stolen scarf to a
stole steal the election rally you have
to love the irony on the audacity quite
frankly so a complete and total liar and
this isn't even the half of it listen to
this next story
George Santos stole a disabled veterans
dog's charity money and the dog died
let that sink in folks
um report from patch.com
disabled veteran George Santos took
three thousand dollars from dying dogs
GoFundMe this one is even worse than it
sounds if you can believe it two New
Jersey veterans veterans say George
Santos promised to raise funds for a
life-saving surgery for a service dog
and then disappeared report out of
Queens in May 2016 Richard osthoff was
living in a tent in an abandoned Chicken
Coop on the side of Route 9 in Howell
New Jersey with his beloved service dog
Sapphire
a veterans charity gave the pit mix to
osthoff who's a disabled veteran
honorably discharged from the Navy
Sapphire the dog developed a
life-threatening stomach tumor osthoff
learned the surgery would cost three
thousand dollars
a vet tech said to osthoff I know a guy
who runs a pet charity who can help you
that guy was Anthony devolder now at
this point you might know Anthony
devolder is the name George Santos used
to use so we're talking about George
Santos the pet charity was called
friends of pets United okay
osthoff and another New Jersey vet
retired police Sergeant Michael bull
tried to intervene to help osthoff in
2016. told patch hey you know what
devalder we'll call him Santos that's
how we know him Santos uh closed the
GoFundMe he set up for Sapphire after it
raised three thousand dollars on social
media
but then disappeared osthoff said he
stopped answering my texts and calls he
posted to Facebook in 2016. to everyone
who helped me and Sapphire raise the
money for her surgery I'm sorry to say
we were scammed by Anthony devolder
through a series of bad Veterinary
contacts and subterfuge regarding
payment Sapphire has not received vet
care her growth is three to four times
bigger than it was when the campaign was
fulfilled she is facing euthanasia
within months Sapphire indeed died
January 15th of 2017.
after being out of work with a broken
leg for over a year osthoff couldn't
even afford the dog's euthanasia and
cremation he had to Panhandle for it
which he called one of the most
degrading things he ever had to do
I contacted Santos and told him you're
messing with a vet give the money back
or use it to get osthoff another dog he
was totally uncooperative on the phone
said bull
I can see why this guy loves Trump
I can see why this guy loves Trump
this is way worse than the headline even
makes it sound and this is the guy
George Santos Anthony devolder who has
now been assigned to multiple committees
the House of Representatives and
apparently I don't know but apparently
is going to be able to weather the media
storm and stick around for two years
despite being one of the most disgusting
individuals I've learned about in all of
my time covering American and World
politics
um I am losing faith that he is going to
be removed I uh he's just he's just
sticking around
and particularly now with committee
assignments it doesn't seem like
Republicans and Kevin McCarthy have any
interest in forcing him out for all we
know and as the speculation uh uh is is
growing McCarthy and Santos struck a
deal Santos supports McCarthy for
speaker McCarthy doesn't try to push him
out and of course the support of the
speaker is a very powerful thing for a
member of Congress particularly a new
one
where will this end what will we next
learn about George Santos Anthony
devolder let me know in the comments
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
and of course all of the clips I played
for you in this segment and earlier
segments are available on our YouTube
channel as well as on our Instagram
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today I'm
going to be speaking with Dr Mary Claire
O'Brien who's a professor of emergency
medicine at Wake Forest University
School of Medicine who was the leading
medical expert in forming the FDA
decision to remove pre-mixed alcoholic
energy drinks from U.S markets back in
2010. it's really great to have you on
today I appreciate it thank you so much
for inviting me so maybe to start with
energy drinks in general when we talk
about what they are I think most people
on understand it's a stimulant of sorts
some of them have caffeine which we're
used to getting when we drink coffee
what exactly is it always caffeine or
are there other stimulant elements in
these energy drinks and how does the
dosage compare to a cup of coffee for
example so those are all very good
questions so from a physiologic
standpoint energy is
but all of us would understand that
really what energy drinks do is deliver
caffeine in one or various forms either
added as a chemical or in guarana or
yerba mate or other things where they're
additives that are essentially just
other forms of caffeine
brewed black coffee has about
uh 34 the average Homebrew black coffee
has about 100 milligrams of caffeine in
it and that's a good strong cup of Home
brewed black coffee and a cola that you
would buy over the counter has about uh
35 or 50 milligrams of caffeine in it
energy drinks are very variable in the
amount of caffeine that they contain
because of a quirk of an FDA situation
in which they are not regulated as
beverage by the Food and Drug
Administration
so you can't pick up a cola on a shelf a
12-ounce Cola that has more than 70
Parts 70 milligrams of caffeine in it
which is 200 parts per million but an
energy drink oddly enough is considered
a dietary supplement by the FDA and they
are not regulated
an energy drink may contain anywhere
from you know 100 to 150 to 200
milligrams of caffeine those little
bitty energy shots that people pick up
all the time have 200 milligrams of
caffeine so in two ounces cold one chug
you're drinking the equivalent of two
very strong cups of hot black coffee
that you would otherwise take your time
to sip and you get that jolt of caffeine
right away when we talk about the
feeling of I have coffee and I feel
awake and energized sometimes there's
the belief that you are getting
something but in it but what's happening
really is that the caffeine is blocking
the Sleep pressure that builds up if I
recall correctly from Michael pollan's
book it's the buildup of adenosine that
over time makes us feel tired so the
caffeine is sort of like the money it's
delaying fee feeling tired really right
that's what it does yes so caffeine
although we call it a stimulant is not a
stimulant what it does is it makes you
feel less sleepy right now for those of
us who are sleepy who want to be
stimulated the feeling of having
caffeine and waking up we all are pretty
familiar with and most of us drink some
caffeinated beverage in the morning
however it is in fact not stimulating
you it's blocking the chemical that's
naturally released in your body that
makes you feel sleepy so so caffeine
makes you feel less sleepy it does not
stimulate you unless of course you talk
about the way that it potentially could
stimulate let's say your heart rate or
your blood pressure when large
quantities are consumed or when normal
quantities are consumed or what would
generally be regarded as safe
insusceptible individuals people who
might be sensitive to the effects of the
caffeine so before we get on to the
energy drink Health stuff how should we
be thinking about what you just
described is it different than how
something like Adderall or amphetamines
work 100 yes
caffeine basically makes you a little it
makes you less sleepy it is not an
addictive substance in the way that we
would think about perhaps
methamphetamine and I'm not sure that
for the average person the difference
between being less sleepy sleepy and
being mildly stimulated makes a whole
lot of practical difference okay it does
however have uh important implications
when we start talking about mixing
energy drinks with alcohol and the idea
that if you take an energy drink or a
hike it could consume large amounts of
caffeine with alcohol that it will
stimulate you and the fact that you feel
a little bit less sleepy means that the
other
Neuropsychiatric effects of alcohol and
motor effects of alcohol are likewise
reduced when they are not okay so before
we introduce the alcohol part what are
the risks of just extremely high doses
of caffeine you know I remember a story
of someone who owned a coffee shop and
for their cold brew they used to
concentrate and one day somebody forgot
that it's supposed to be watered down
and all of a sudden the caffeine green
dose in a cup is 10x what it's supposed
to be whether it's a caffeine in coffee
or an energy drink what are the risks of
too much caffeine too quickly
so the answer to that question
preceded by it depends on whom are the
effects okay so in healthy individuals
who are not otherwise susceptible the
FDA says we shouldn't consume more than
400 milligrams of caffeine so let's say
four cups of coffee less than that is
generally regarded as safe unless you
have a pre-existing condition which you
might not know about but anyway that's
what's generally for a healthy
non-pregnant non-nursing adult that's
considered safe over what period of time
in one day in a day okay
yeah for pregnant or nursing individuals
that number is 200 milligrams so no more
than two cups of coffee and it's not
saying that that is a good idea but it's
saying we think that's generally
regarded as safe
in adolescence it's 100 milligrams so
that's a strong cup of coffee but most
of us aren't going to give our 12 year
olds a strong cup of coffee in the
morning before they go to school but
that's the number or the limit that's
sort of been set by the FDA and then for
uh children there is absolutely no safe
level whatsoever zero American Academy
of Pediatrics even though uh they state
that 30 to 50 percent of adolescents
drink energy drinks there is absolutely
no level of safety established in
children adolescents should not drink
energy drinks children should not drink
energy drinks hard stop and when we talk
about the negative Health consequences
that having more than that 400
milligrams can have what are they
so I think uh most of us who've had a
little bit too much caffeine or had it
too late at night have experienced
jitteriness insomnia nervousness
sometimes at higher doses ringing in the
ears it can cause stomach upset nausea
uh there are it can cause flushing it's
also curiously thought chronic levels of
caffeine ingestion are thought to
decrease calcium absorption so one of
the things you worry about is over time
adolescents women drinking high levels
of caffeine or steady levels of caffeine
will that predispose to osteoporosis so
it definitely interferes with calcium
metabolism and then in pregnant
individuals high and or heavy use of
caffeine habitually has been associated
with increased risk for miscarriage and
for having babies that are small for
gestational age at Birth now that's all
you know most of us have been familiar
uh with some of the side effects that we
would get but remember in susceptible
individuals there are people who can't
even drink a single cup of coffee and
how do you know that you don't know
until you get you know superventricular
tachycardia and now guess what you can
only have decaf right which is not no
calf but you know much less cap so when
we introduce the alcohol component and
this could be an energy drink that is
already alcohol plus the caffeine in the
package it can also be the infamous Red
Bull and vodka right I mean these are
also drinks that one can kind of mix on
their own what happens when you combine
the two
so the pre-mixed alcoholic energy drinks
which is the terminology that was used
pre-mixed alcoholic energy drinks and I
won't mention the brands because I don't
want to give them air time but they're
they are 100 off the market in the
United States right and that and that is
because uh it is a very clear that
um increasing that mixing caffeine in
alcohol those pre-packaged things which
was never permitted by the FDA was never
permitted it's just the industry got
away with it until the FDA called them
um that uh that it is associated with
increased amount of drinking heavy
drinking binge episodes
so have your drinking more frequent
heavy drinking and an increased risk of
serious alcohol-related consequences
like driving with an intoxicated driver
being sexually assaulted assaulting
someone else sexually and being hurt or
injured enough to need to seek medical
attention and what we believe is that
the alcohol or pardon me that the
caffeine masks some of the cues that you
might get that you had had too much to
drink that the caffeine masks that for
the alcohol so you're still drunk if
you've drunk enough alcohol to get to be
drunk but you perceive because of the
caffeine that you're not as drunk as you
think you are and what you are is been
well described as a wide awake drunk and
that's a dangerous thing because you
think you're okay and you are not so
when we read about people who go to the
ER after combining these types of
elements and from what I've read one in
ten of those ER visits leads to a
hospitalization what is it people are
showing up with with what what is it
that leads to them ending up at the ER
so what happens is they go to a drinking
situation where they intend to party
sometimes they preload with a
caffeinated beverage sometimes they
consume the caffeine while they're
consuming the alcohol two things happen
one is that the caffeine starts to wear
off before the alcohol does because
alcohol is metabolized at a steady state
it doesn't matter how much you drink if
you have five beers or ten beers you're
going to chip away or your liver will at
how much alcohol there is independent of
how much you drunk you only can
metabolize a certain amount of an hour
those of us who drink caffeine are aware
that if you have two cups of coffee at
eight o'clock by one o'clock in the
afternoon you're ready for another cup
of coffee and this is because of the
half-life processing of the caffeine
versus linear with alcohol that is 100
correct so there's two things that
happen one is that the that the caffeine
uh starts to wear off before the alcohol
wears off
the second thing what that permits you
to do is to stay awake longer so if you
drink 10 beers you're going to pass out
but if you've High loaded on a lot of
caffeine the same amount of alcohol
might not make you pass out you keep
drinking longer so when the caffeine
wears off folks come into the emergency
department basically comatose because
they've drunk far more alcohol than they
would otherwise have been able to
tolerate without passing out because
they have had the effect of the caffeine
keeping them helping them to stay awake
longer wow yeah you know anecdotally I
I've had experience with this not in the
situation you're describing but since I
was a kid I I would have a sort of like
vasovagal episodes where I would faint
and as an adult I had a situation where
before boarding a flight in Rome I had
an espresso with my girlfriend in the
waiting area because it's Rome right I
mean what do people do and then on the
plane they served free wine I never have
alcohol on airplanes but I said I get
it's a long flight we're watching a
movie I'll have it was one espresso and
one glass of wine I was very dehydrated
and I fainted on a plane and it became a
horrible thing I needed you know 30 days
of a heart monitor to make sure I was
okay it was just one of these episodes
but that seems to be another and and
that's also that same combination of how
these things operate right it is and and
what that would tell you that you as an
individual are susceptible right so even
though the FDA would say oh you could
have up to Four Strong cups of coffee
every day you know better because you've
had the experience of mixing one
espresso with one glass of alcohol and
your body does not tolerate it right how
do you know whether or not you're one of
the susceptible individuals you have to
have something bad happening yeah I
figured it out right yeah what are the
um for people who regularly consume
either significant amounts of energy
drinks with or without the the alcohol
combination but in either case what do
we know about long-term health effects
so that's a very very good question and
one of the things that is challenging in
the research is that human studies on
caffeine high levels of caffeine over
long periods of time are really limited
by two things the first is tremendous
variation in individual sensitivity to
caffeine and then in the way it the
amount in which caffeine the rate at
which caffeine is metabolized so you
metabolize caffeine a little bit
differently than I do and that's because
we're all individuals because I'm a
woman you're a man you may or may not
smoke cigarettes you may or may not be
taking medications that would affect
your caffeine metabolism and so
individuals even if you had 10
individuals sign up for a lab trial
going into it that confounds the study
and secondly we we worry long term about
the cardiovascular side effects in
particular and again about bone density
and and the ability to do the research
that would establish it is ethically
constrained for that reason particularly
so for women when they're concerned
about re where there are concerns about
reproductive effects of long-term use of
caffeine
when we talk about studies that make
claims and this is more General I think
about coffee than it is about energy
drinks per se but I'm curious your
thoughts uh you know drinking two to
three cups of coffee a day is associated
with longer lifespan right this is a
common thing and it's sort of like with
eggs coffee is good and then it's bad
and then it's good and it depends how
you test it or who you ask or when you
know with anything food and drink
related it seems that part of the
difficulty is whenever you're adding or
taking something away you're always
replacing with something else and it can
be hard to know whether the effect is
from the removal of some or what is the
best science we currently have about
those types of claims about a couple of
cups of coffee and longevity
so what we do know is that healthy
non-pregnant non-nursing individuals can
include an energy drink or a strong cup
of coffee or two in their daily diet
with
um in moderation
so just like you would do anything else
in moderation for healthy non-pregnant
non-nursing individuals
caffeine in moderation is thought to be
generally regarded as safe
and that's what we know now that's
extraordinarily narrow language it is
generally regarded
this yeah uh did you know when when my
girlfriend uh when we were in the
process of starting a pregnancy
um she was told by by a doctor that some
of the assistive
medications that exist we don't
currently believe they increase the risk
of reproductive cancers which again when
I hear that I say it sounds like they
might it sounds like they might and so
we really don't know
uh we know that it's generally regarded
as safe okay that's what we know uh with
the exceptions for pregnancy for nursing
uh for adolescents and for individuals
who might be susceptible whoever they
are yeah okay wow which I guess I guess
the answer is we maybe would like to
know more than we actually do know right
now
true remember that the there are
constraints around science that would
establish what's safe part of it is the
individual metabolism absorption of
these substances and then part of it is
the constraints over long-term health
effects that are unknown and and and
that limit our ability to reproduce in
the laboratory what people commonly do
in real life right
um last thing I wanted to ask you about
do you think that so obviously with the
pre-mixed drinks they're off the shelf
it's a regulatory decision that that was
made when it comes to I mean you tell me
coffee of different kinds or energy
drinks that are just energy drinks do
you think there needs to be more
regulation or government involvement or
is it really just about educating people
and making people aware of the amounts
of these things that they're consuming
so you asked my opinion so I'm going to
give you an opinion yes and I and I
think it's poppycock that they are
regulated as dietary supplements uh
their Beverages and that was a decision
made in the mid-1990s the decision that
the FDA made about limiting the caffeine
in Cola beverages was made in 1959 and
the energy drinks really came onto the
market in the 1990s uh particular late
1980s early 1990s and in the mid 1990s
the FDA made a decision that said these
are dietary supplements they're they're
not Beverages and if they were regulated
in the same way as are the can of
Coca-Cola that you can buy in the
grocery store right next to them then
that would make more sense to me I think
it's poppycock and if they were
regulated in the same way as soda the
differences would be labeling or also
there would be limits that would be
placed yeah there would be limits so we
mentioned guarana and yerba mate those
are both natural sources of caffeine and
so they are listed as additives to
energy drinks they're more caffeine now
I did a little research to prepare for
speaking with you and looked at a couple
of things on the shelf and most of them
most of the beverages that I saw do list
the amount of caffeine that's in them
okay however there is not
um
I just think we would not you would not
uh give you know three or four cups of
coffee to your average 13 year old you
would not let a kid in high school think
that an energy drink could serve as a
sports drink when they're not you you
would and yet that's what goes on yeah
yeah
wow
well we will see if that ever is there
an appetite to change that do you think
it doesn't seem like it or there is oh
okay there is and and letters have been
written by a couple of senators and
these this goes back a while though yeah
is there a current appetite no was there
a lot of appetite in the wake of the
research about the health effects of of
energy drinks and alcohol yes did that
did that stir the pot about the health
effects of energy drinks at all
without alcohol yes has that uh energy
and enthusiasm for making change
continued it has not over the last
decade and I'm not sure why that is
understood um understood we've been
speaking with Dr Mary Claire O'Brien
professor of emergency medicine at Wake
Forest University School of Medicine
thank you so much for your time
appreciate your insights you're welcome
I am impressed with your level of
knowledge about the science of the
subject and you can call me anytime
thank you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
we are now talking about Trump perjury
Trump reportedly lying many times during
a completely unhinged deposition which
we have some of the trans transcripts of
and the full transcript is yet to be
released but apparently will be Newsweek
reporting Donald Trump may have severely
damaged his case in the defamation
lawsuit brought against him by a woman
who accused him of rape by expressing
quote repeated lies during his
deposition according to an attorney
Katie Fang who's a legal analyst in
MSNBC host was reacting to the unsealed
transcripts of testimony Trump gave this
is the E Gene Carroll lawsuit Carol
accused Trump of raping her in the mid
90s Trump denies it Carol is now suing
Trump for defaming her character
including stating in a 2019 interview he
wouldn't have raped her because she is
not his type which is
an absolutely insane thing to say Trump
later repeated the same remark on Troth
Central in October of 2022. trough
Central right before the deposition took
place
during his testimony which was unsealed
Monday Trump defended is not my type
remarks while calling the rape claim a
hoax and calling the accuser a whack job
and a liar
um Fang said the legal significance is
Trump steps in it over and over again
and more importantly he basically denies
flat out he's ever touched a woman and
any part of her body specifically is
denying touching a woman on the breast
or buttocks or any other sexual part
without her consent
he said no under oath the whole world
knows that on an Access Hollywood tape
he boasted about how he would grab them
by the blank and you can do it when
you're a star he's caught in repeated
lies throughout the course of his sworn
videotaped a deposition there is now a
bunch of the transcript and it is wacky
you can just imagine Trump talking about
this he was asked you say she completely
made up a story that I met her at the
doors of this crowded New York City
Department Store and within minutes
swooned her do you see that Trump says
yeah
what does swooned her mean Trump that
would be a word may be accurate or not
having to do with talking to her and
talking to her to do an act that she
said happened which didn't happen and
it's a nicer word than the word that
starts with an f and this would be a
word that I use because I thought it
would be inappropriate to use the other
word and it didn't happen
anybody know what he's talking about the
question that follows okay I was curious
when I read this so I looked up the word
swoon in the dictionary and under the
dictionary it means to faint with
extreme emotion that's not what you
meant here Trump says well sort of
that's what she said I did to her She
fainted with great emotion she actually
indicated that she loved okay she loved
it until commercial break in fact I
think she said it was sexy didn't she
she said it was very sexy to be raped
didn't she say that
so sir I just want to confirm it's your
testimony that e Gene Carroll said she
loved being sexually assaulted by you
Trump says well based on her interview
with Anderson Cooper I believe that's
what took place and we could Define that
you'll have to show that I'm sure you're
going to show that but she was
interviewed by Anderson Cooper and I
think she said rape was sexy which it's
not by the way Trump clarifies
um
I hope we at some point get video of
this deposition because it is absolutely
and completely insane but importantly
lying during a deposition can have very
serious legal consequences including
perjury charges perjury is a criminal
offense it can result in imprisonment it
can result in fines but of course
remember
proving perjury is very difficult this
is why I mean listen you and I know
people lie all the time under oath in
court they say things that aren't true
and many of them know that the things
they're saying are untrue but why don't
you often see perjury charges because in
order to get a perjury charge to stick
you have to demonstrate that the person
knew what they were saying was untrue
rather than it was the result of a
mistaken recollection or a lack of
recollection or whatever the case may be
very very difficult the other issue with
lying during a deposition is that you
can be held in contempt
this is all so unlikely to happen to
Trump but it is again more of Trump's
dishonesty more of Trump's inability to
just shut his mouth and
um answer very directly only what is
being asked and lawyers are now saying
many many lies here and it is perjury
what is ultimately going to happen with
the EG and Carol lawsuit we don't know
understand that we now have
the federal investigation into Trump
the New York investigation into Trump
the Georgia investigation into Trump
wearing a grand jury recently finished
its work and we're waiting could be any
day we find out whether Trump is going
to be charged there uh we have this
lawsuit we have the cases against
Trump's organization I'm sure I'm not
even covering all of it and the next
thing involves Rudy Giuliani including
Rudy's claim that Trump told him hey
Rudy take some of these top secret files
to your house let's talk talk about that
next
Rudy Giuliani
humiliated lawyer Rudy Giuliani who once
represented failed former president
Donald Trump is now saying very clearly
and very directly Trump would tell me
takes top secret files home with you
take them home with you Rudy we don't
even know if Rudy had a clearance to
look at those files never mind he
obviously should not be taking them home
Business Insider reports Rudy Giuliani
says Trump once told him to take top
secret documents home Giuliani said the
incident occurred just after Trump
became President when he was working at
Mar-A-Lago Giuliani said he did not
bring the documents home
Giuliani says he was at Mar-A-Lago
working on quote vetting some quote very
rich people specifically going through
their tax returns for Trump this
happened right after Trump became
president quote when I was his lawyer I
mean there was a period of time I was
there like 10 straight days Giuliani
said on the Sunday episode of the WABC
77 radio show uncovering the truth with
Rudy Giuliani and Dr Maria Ryan
I didn't take listen to this this is my
training on top secret I didn't take him
out of Mar-A-Lago describing how he
handled the documents he told me oh take
them home with you Giuliani said of
trump I'm not going to take Wilbur
Ross's tax returns home with me I could
misplace them I you know I never ever
ever ever ever knowingly and I never got
caught but I don't remember ever taking
a document Giuliani said he said he
would put the documents in a small safe
at his desk in Mar-A-Lago to be worked
on the next day Giuliani also said top
secret files are quote very very strange
the way they're put together and often
are very small but they contain a lot of
information
Giuliani and a spokesman for Trump did
not immediately respond now put aside
just for a moment take them home there's
a broader question did Rudy Giuliani
have a security clearance throughout his
time
um working in this capacity to even look
at those documents and the answer is we
don't know
um back in 2019 Maguire says he doesn't
know if Giuliani had a security
clearance acting Director of National
Intelligence Joseph McGuire said he
doesn't know whether Trump's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani has security
clearance amid questions over his role
in Trump's interactions with Ukraine's
president Maguire said I don't know
whether or not Giuliani has a security
clearance this came in response to
questioning from Congressman Mike
Quigley about whether it was improper
for Giuliani to be involved in Trump
asking zelenski to investigate Biden and
Hunter
uh multiple reports about that if you go
back to that point in time on MSNBC
acting dni doesn't know if Rudy Giuliani
had a security clearance even if you
have a clearance it's not like you can
just be Waltzing in and out and looking
through files and I think this is one of
the important details that should be
added just sort of generally when we
have these conversations about
classified document security clearances
Etc
having a clearance is necessary to be
able to look at a lot of different
documents and files but it is not
sufficient and what's important to
understand and a couple of lawyers wrote
to me about this and explained it to me
clearly this the clearance is required
to even be eligible to look at a lot of
the stuff but in addition you have to
have some connection to it you have to
have some need to know there has to be
some reason some Nexus as to why you and
the document are coming into contact and
with a lot of these issues it seems as
though there are some that believe
if you have a particular clearance you
can just willy-nilly on a whim at any
point in time grab the files that are uh
um in line with that security clearance
with no actual operational or Working
Connection to them you can't at least
not the way the the rules and the law is
written now what was going on in Trump's
White House we know that with Jared
Kushner and some others they they didn't
even really they weren't supposed to get
security clearances but then there was
like an override done and they got them
anyway we covered it years ago we really
don't know what the standard operating
procedure was but Trump telling Rudy
just take documents home is very much in
line with what we have seen and learned
about over those many years are any of
these people ever going to be held
accountable no I mean this is sort of
like a footnote
and uh you know multiple criminal
investigations into Trump Rudy Giuliani
disbarred in some places all these
things this is so comparatively minor
under Obama it would have been
absolutely and totally huge they would
it would be a week on Fox news but with
Rudy and Trump it's just like a little
footnote it's not going anywhere sadly
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P we talked about the
inflation numbers last week we talked
about food as a component of the total
inflation numbers we talked about by the
way one person who wrote to me and said
David inflation can't be down because
eggs are expensive I forgot to mention
in that story
the following which a caller does
mention thankfully about why eggs
specifically are pricey right now hey
David Carolyn from Minnesota yes ma'am
I'm talking about the price of eggs did
everybody forget we had the avian flu
right
thank you yes this is one component to
why egg prices
have out uh not outperformed perform
makes it sound good this is why egg
prices have remained and continued up
even as inflation has declined and this
avian flu outbreak is absolutely a
component to that I mentioned this you
know I get the I don't know how I got
sucked in because I basically I I don't
eat so many eggs that a couple bucks one
way or the other makes a difference so I
read you really want not grass-fed or
whatever grass-fed is is BS you want 100
pasture raised eggs
and so I fell for it and I fell for it I
I mean it sounds pretty good to me I can
tell you the yolks are much more orange
and you do like to see that it looks
healthy anyway these pasture-raised eggs
that I get they used to be like 5.99 a
dozen then 649 then 6.99 now they're up
to 7.49. I'm still buying them and again
I go through so few eggs that we're
talking about a difference of like three
dollars a month but I have noticed that
the eggs have remained high and indeed
the avian flu outbreaks are a factor
which hopefully will not continue to be
a factor too much longer we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today it is
really easy to get the bonus show all
you have to do is sign up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yes everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
as bad as a member you not only get
access to the bonus show you get a
commercial free audio and video stream
of the show every day you also get
launching very soon a soundboard like
mine just for members thank your lucky
stars every day you're not Dave Pacman
if you want to prank your friends if you
want to do whatever it is people would
do with my soundboard by popular demand
we are releasing the soundboard to our
members very very soon and so you will
be able to do things like truth
essential a really great time we're all
very mature here on the show okay you
sign up at joinpakman.com what's on
today's bonus show the White House and
Secret Service are saying no visitor
logs for Biden's Delaware home we don't
have them they don't exist you're not
getting them okay this is related to the
classified document investigation the
new monument in Boston dedicated to
Martin Luther and Coretta Scott King
has sparked serious debate and has
widely triggered many on the right but
has also been mocked by people on the
left as well
and lastly the gas stove is the new
battle line in American culture wars I
am going to make an extremely important
Declaration on the bonus show about my
relationship to gas stoves present and
future I think many in the audience will
be shocked by what I'm going to announce
but I'm going to announce it nonetheless
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at jointpaclin.com
we'll see you then
foreign